[موسيقى]
اختفاء رمضان ومن معه اثار فزعه محبي
الصقور والبدو والذين انطلقوا بالمئات
بحثا عنهم في هذه الصحراء الشائعه حتى
وصلوا اليه اخيرا وقد فاضت روحهم الى
بارئها
مباشره
عبد المولى اخوه الشهيد رمضان بالفزعه
طبعا احنا قبائل بدويه يعني كلمه الفزع
عندنا لها دور كبير جدا
الفزعه يعني النجده
بلا استثناء كل القبائل من كل المحافظات
من محافظه مطروح تواجد في المكان حوالي
400 عربيه سياره دفع رباعي اول يوم توقدوا
حوالي 100 150 عربيه ثاني يوم بقى العدد
بتزايد من محافظات عده ناس بتيجي من الشرق
للطلب كانت بجميع طوائف في البدو القبائل
تعاطف مع الموضوع
برده
كل واحد ندي له حقه زي جيشنا برده العظيم
مخابرات المصريه طلعت طيران خاص للبحث
عنهم واا تحركت الطيران على طول وهم اللي
انتم احداثيه برده بالمكان يعني وكان دور
كبير برده وفعال معنا من الجماعه
المشاهدين همم في همم في الموقف لهم دور
كبير برده معنا في المساعده فارق معانا
وناس كانت حاضره من كل يعني انا باقول لك
يعني عشنا صعايده وفلاحين وناس كلهم عاشوا
عاشوا معنا اللحظه دي كلها يعني كلهم يعني
بمعنى الكلمه فزعوا
لحد ما وصلنا النقطه كان وصلها جميل جسمي
من قبيله الجواسم
وبلغه بالحداسيه واحد برده ثاني من البدو
وكان معدي هناك وجوده السيارات وصلنا
للعربيه لان العربيه لوحدها فجاه بصينا
لقيناها كاتب عمل السهم بطاريه سهم كده
على على الارض على الرمال وكاتب مخلصين
الميه
كل بعد المسافه بيعمل سهم بقى بعد ما
اتجاهه من كلمه مخلصين ميه بقى بيدي
اشارات لانه رمضان كبره كخبير جدا الصحراء
فيعني كان عاملها سبب من اسباب النجاح همم
ولكن افات المانيه القدر ان هو همم
يعني توفاه